la presidenta de Honduras
Xiomara Castro cumplirá este viernes su
primer año de mandato entre el optimismo
por algunos logros sociales y políticos
y las críticas de la oposición y otros
sectores que consideran que no ha
cumplido con las promesas que hizo en
campaña y al asumir el poder en un
mensaje que ha sido reiterativo la
mandataria Indicó que al asumir el poder
el 27 de enero de 2022 encontró un
acelerado deterioro de las finanzas
públicas en todas las esferas
gubernamentales un alto nivel de
endeudamiento y una tragedia humana de
más de 6 millones de personas sometidas
a la pobreza extrema y una alta
inflación
su mandato No ha sido fácil No solo por
los problemas económicos y sociales que
heredó sino por otros de índole político
como una confrontación interna en el
partido libre con un movimiento interno
que quería presidir el parlamento cuya
presencia por un acuerdo con el psh ya
estaba comprometida para 2023 Castro
prevé la ejecución de más obra social y
material y que se instale en el país una
comisión internacional contra la
corrupción y la impunidad para lo que a
finales de 2022 su gobierno suscribió un
memorándum de entendimiento con
organización de las Naciones Unidas
[Aplausos]